are you ready yeah go this show is
brought to you by a cash up the number
one finance half in the App Store cash
app is the simplest way to send to
receive money especially with your
friends oh you or when you owe them when
have you last used it um I last used the
cash app to send my friend money for gas
what and that's just the true tea that's
a very scalding yeah that's what I do i
if you take me somewhere I gave you gas
money I gave them $15 gas in is la is
ridiculous I'm talking on you now gas
laughing I talked about cash app is also
the easiest way to try and grow your
money in the stock market with their
investing feature app you can instantly
invest in stock as little as $1 I stood
in mid-sentence wrong he's hot he's
whatever he does is just fine
did you know that brokerage services are
provided by cash app investing a
subsidiary of square member SLP ste me
personally I've heard as always when you
sign it for the cash app use the promo
code ok Whitney reading backwards you'll
receive $10 at the cash app will also
donate $10 to The Trevor Project an
amazing organization that provides
Protective Services to lgbtqia+ youth
across America don't
from a co Whitney when you download the
cash app from the App Store today
Oh exclamation today Gary Gulman are we
friends yes I can say no okay I mean I
don't really know you right this is kind
of wild that the first time we're
hanging out is only being recorded well
we did meet at Caroline's in around 2007
and we talked for a little bit of like a
Christmas party that's right yeah I was
in - it was mm you were intimidated by
me yes oh wow yes that's unusual I
disagree my like everyone that I started
comedy with you were like the gold
standard really yes it's news to me yeah
I think comedians we tend to talk shit
to each other's faces and good backs
right yeah like parents I've talked good
behind your back a lot oh that's so nice
did I tell you right I cuz I remember
like we'd be writing jokes and it was
like oh no Gary Gulman would make this
last for 30 minute he could write about
this like this joke we should keep
milking it that's what we thought right
right milking it and getting every
possible angle right because it came
from I think being in LA or maybe even
in Boston where it was so hard to get on
stage that you couldn't really try out
new stuff you had to have stuff that
worked and try to make that longer so
that was my it was like a what do you
call that necessity out of necessity but
I used to beat myself up using you
really flagellate myself with your act
because I'd be like why can't I remember
jerks about this like it's ridiculous
like Gary Goldman can write 40 minutes
on sugar cookies like I'm suck like a
you know a lot of people go like I want
to become a comedian because of that
person I wanted to stop doing comedy
every time I say oh well I feel that way
with so many comedians Brian Regan was
that way for me every time I saw him I
would think why do I even how do you
have one minute peanut butter and jelly
oh I know I end and approaches and
angles that nobody's even considered
like he'd the one thing that I always
say it's enough with the airplane humor
unless you're Brian Regan yes a fresh
take about how the the pilot has found
20 million dollars and he's trying to
figure out how to split it up before
that that's why they can't take off in
time because we're gonna split it up
amongst everybody on the plane I mean
he's just inspiring my favorite but also
he makes me want to quit that's correct
yeah that's correct because I'm just
like I could never think that way yes
you know but I always I always had this
thought about you where I was like you
know cuz I think comedians for the most
part like I think and part of the reason
I do it is you can kind of release your
shame by talking about the grossest
parts of yourself and just sort of and
then people laughs you're able I'll
commit into something good you know I'm
yeah oh well all of these horrible
things that happened
can't be for nothing because I then can
make people laugh I compare there's
redemption and revenge yes but I
remember like the first couple years I
watched you I sort of was like there's
not a lot of darkness here yeah you know
right and I was always curious like
right there just no darkness at all
their life so much darkness but I didn't
have the confidence or maybe even the
skill level to to make it funny I would
try every once in a while I would try to
talk about something on stage and then
if it didn't work right away I'd be like
that's too dark I can't I can't go in
that direction and yeah because I
remember you had a joke you had a joke
that was Gary's doing ASMR put the mic
you had a joke I'm gonna botch it but it
was like if someone please invent a
orange juice that you can drink within
two days of brushing your teeth oh yeah
yeah yeah or another I remember or a
toothpaste you can use with it two days
before brushing your teeth yes a
toothpaste that yeah I can't remember it
either but it was about that it was like
everyone's had that problem but no
Camille
had put it in the wording that made it
like maximum like relatable and funny
and I just remember going like that
can't be his biggest struggle no because
if there's a comedian performing not
talking about their demons like what's
going on yeah with them and I remember
when I heard you were going through some
tough times I was like it just like was
so yeah overwhelming and just sort of
like oh yeah he never got to release it
on stage he never got to sublimated into
his work yeah well I think yeah I mean I
may have I may have written myself into
a corner where it's like nobody wants to
hear about the misery of the the cookies
guy and so it was hard to make that make
that adjustment and so I had to do it
rather dramatically like like to go up
there and talk about the level of
depression I had say when I moved out
here in 2000 it wasn't that compelling
there weren't that I wasn't hospitalized
I would just sound like a lot of other
comedians who were struggling and then
when I I guess when I got to the point
where I was in hospital and and one of
my British in the hospital yeah in the
in the hospital I and then I did it's
taking my yeah yes yes and then and then
electroconvulsive therapy and all the
other things was like okay now it's now
it's different from for most the other
comedians and also if I go onstage
looking and shaking like this because my
anxiety was so bad that I was shaking
all the time and if I go on stage doing
this somebody's gonna be like what the
what the hell is wrong with this guy so
I had to address it so it was again
necessity yeah yes he overate yeah do
you find that the word depression is
being overused these days like just well
no but I I also think I mean I I agree
with what you're saying but there's also
I have to tell people that you don't
have to be at the level I was to go get
help
yes I mean I got help early on at a
level that was far from now that was
just I was just a very high
functioning depressive who could stay up
really late getting the things done that
I had been unable to get done all day
long and also I had kind of a rhythm to
my depression where I would feel much
better at night than I did in the
morning you talk yourself out yeah yeah
and then there were there were sort of
periods of three to six months where I
felt great and I would get everything
done and then fall apart and and go back
into a into a hole for a while so there
was a this has become like an amnesia
where you're like oh that was that was
just a phase that passed under the woods
the thing is is that I think I needed it
to get this bad in order for me not to
have that in M&A sure yeah because I
find that this recovery seems to be the
sturdiest because I'm so vigilant yeah
like we were just talking how I'm like I
have to run today or I'm gonna spend the
rest of the week in the fetal position
because I
III really need it especially when I
travel traveling is you get out of your
routine and it's it's hard to maintain
yeah and I also find I mean traveling is
exhausting I think especially for
sensitive people cuz you're around so
many people you don't know you're taking
on their stuff you're taking on their
energy you strike me as empathic like
like it's funny when people are like oh
sorry I couldn't I couldn't text you
I've been traveling all day and I was
like you mean you were sitting in one
place for eight hours no I know you
couldn't see one like what is so
exhausting about job like you got to
keep track of your bags you got to make
sure the gate but otherwise like what
I'm so tired about it yes I yeah I
actually find myself a little bit free
when I'm in the yeah one of them in the
airports I love it yeah but it but I do
think for people like us sensitive
people and are constantly taking on
other people's stuff and judging and
looking for jokes like I do find in an
airport my brain is kind of an overdrive
because I'm so disgusted by people's
behavior no but I'll make up seven seats
with one backpack yeah oh my gosh
the wild amount of injustice --is that I
that I witness out during the day and
and you know the New York sub
you know there are men who are taking up
to its two spaces the old lady is barely
home yeah yes she's barely holding on
and slipping and sliding all over the
place and this guy needs so much space
for his two legs and he says it drives
me insane when I see someone at the
airport sitting and they put one bag on
each side yes it should be in front of
you on the on the chair once you get one
chair yeah I don't care if the whole
thing's empty yeah it's just it's it's
like compact yes why can't check it yes
check your luggage why can't everyone be
as neurotic neurotic and full and I
don't want to take up any space as us
everybody
oh they're trash people just put their
trash on the seat which is while they're
sitting on the floor lying down or
people who don't have an anxiety attack
trying to figure out where to put their
trash at Whole Foods between the compost
and the recycling and I I just what
compost is you can't include the paper
yes holder's doesn't see it out it's the
Rhines man finish it there should be
nothing left for $18 ice scraping
there's nothing there's right I'm eating
the rinds
yes I'm consuming all of it for that
amount of money all right seed every
rind yes I I mean I just but I'll see a
plastic cup in the compost and I want to
burn the entire place down I used I
always think everything is a scam and
philosophy I just thought it was all
going to the same place and just giving
people the idea
maybe that's the reveal at the end of
our life maybe that's just the delusion
I tell myself because I don't want to go
through the whole thing yeah but I in
watching your special it was it was I
hate saying this but this is what people
say I hate that when I watched it I was
like oh my god I never would have known
do you all say that no I mean I feel
like it it's it's part of the I don't
know if it's part of the illness but
part of my version of the illness was
keeping it from all but two or three
people and my and my therapist and just
so many people over the years I've let
go because I couldn't keep in touch I
just didn't have the the energy and I
remember people saying I you never
called me back I never heard from you
and I and I say yeah I wasn't I wasn't
feeling well so it's been great to
reconnect with so many people and also
over the past two years to sort of re
relive certain things because one of the
things that's so frustrating is you
don't enjoy things that you used to yeah
I'm joy and and so for me I used to love
playing basketball and then it became
too much of a hassle for me to get to
the court and I would be disappointed in
my performance you couldn't get out of
bed yeah out of bed and then I would I
would think I'm just gonna miss a whole
bunch of shots and feel lousy about that
and and and now III play so frequently
and I watch it and I just it's like
rediscovering that this thing that I had
I had forgotten brought me so much joy
like like pure joy can I be really
granular about about yeah I I I know I
think enough to understand like how
addiction works and how it thrives on
shame and secrecy like you're only as
sick as the secrets you guys is
depression like that as well the more I
keep it from people I think worse it
gets I think there are so many analogous
aspects of depression too and I've found
over the years that that a lot of the
tenants and and philosophies in in AI
and and and na are applicable to to
depression one that I I remember my I
used to go to a lot of meetings with it
with a friend and one thing that people
would always say was compare and despair
and that's all show business Instagram
yes yes and and so that's something I
had to take into account and also just
to pause it for a second that's so
fascinating cuz you know a lot of people
probably were comparing themselves to
you for a long time not even knowing
what was actually going on so
a lot of things were comparing ourselves
things that don't even exist how I know
because I know we're putting out a false
version of themselves a lot of times
were you know comparing ourselves to a
hallucination anyway I know but I still
have to catch myself even even now when
I when I think of somebody you see
somebody who you think is so great and
you're like well I need to work harder
and then I realize that may be true but
it is not the answer to me feeling
better about myself
you said something somewhere I don't
know where it was where Chris Rock said
- you were sort of I won't put words in
your mouth oh yeah comparing yourself to
someone else's career and oh this was
with Bert Kreischer yes yes and it
really hit me because I think it's it's
I always am trying to find the balance
between healthy competition and going
and healthy motivation of going okay
this person got this thing I can get
that thing - yeah I need a little bit of
that right sure just part of how I
function I'm not saying it's healthy but
it's just no it's fine and it's human
nature 100% yeah and and compare and
despair and an unhealthy obsession with
someone else that sir you know just a
lot of I'll be like well that person got
that I need to get a - and I don't even
wanna know why Mel I know why am i
trying to get check that box just
because someone else did I know you know
I don't even want that thing I don't
want to do cruises why am i doing what
am i forcing myself to do things just
because someone else is doing it but
what was it the Chris Rock if you want
to become that you will become though
well yeah who's talking about this
comedian who you you'll laugh when I
tell you who it is afterwards but
Chrysler and I we're talking about him
and we just we really just wanted to get
feature work on the road that's when you
open from yeah yeah yeah yeah and Chris
Rock said if you want to be that guy
that's what you'll be you want feature
good feature work and that's and that's
the the highest you'll climb and compare
but try to become some least strike yeah
yes yes it was great it was great advice
he seems so obvious now but if you're
gonna manifest or the secret alright at
least yeah I remember the first time I
did like a vision board
when I moved to Los Angeles I believe in
the vision board by the way I think I
also think it's almost uncanny so a
vision board is something you put images
that you want to achieve on a board but
I also think the type of person who
takes time to make a vision board is
also the type of person who works hard
on their comedy yes it's a great point
yeah it just does it never writes a joke
yes that's so that's so true you know
it's like the kind of the act of collage
not so much that's what they will find
out years and later it's not the visions
it's the collaging it was collages is
the decoupage yes and the glue gun yes
no magic it's the same thing with this
theory about taking vitamins like
vitamins might not be what's making you
healthy but the type of person that goes
out and takes the vitamin every day is
really insightful probably also true yes
the statisticians would say yes you
can't tell from this because there's
yeah there's there's a type of nerd does
you're already type-a so I'm a little
bit you know but
vision boards like I remember when I
first I was scared to aim too high you
know oh yeah yeah yeah and yeah because
somebody could see it and think you're
crazy oh I had guys find my vision board
I got a guy find my vision board in my
closet and I remember because it I had
put glitter on it or something I'm like
I had really gone for yeah yeah yeah and
he was like what's all this glitter and
he opens a closet and my vision board
fell out it was like me nice toast man
Wow The Tonight Show I mean mother yeah
yeah right the tonight yeah I had with
Conan and Letterman
yes no and then I had but there was
something that was so funny
that was actually beneath me like at the
time that I revealed to have my first
one how low my self-esteem was right
good nights in Raleigh North Carolina
[Laughter]
like I think the issue here is not
manifesting it's just my self-esteem in
John oh yeah yeah yeah
the reasonable vision board achievable
one but I do think is important too - I
was reading about how how we can
quantify happiness and one of the main
things they can prove is that achieving
goals yeah is a big one like even in a
small way like my thing was like I'm
gonna go to the gym and I'm just gonna
like do whatever hits me I thought that
was progress cuz my stuff is crippling
perfectionism and control and so I said
you know what I'm just gonna start going
to the gym and whatever happens happens
I'm just gonna be flexible I'm right I'm
taneous I'm gonna feel it out and then
you'll evening like I'm not clear on
what setting vague goals totally is
really bad no I totally agree with that
you don't get dopamine out of it you got
I now I'm like I used to make fun of the
people the gym that have their little
notebooks the dorks I know they're doing
the right thing that's right now I'm
like I'm do 50 of these 50 these 50 of
these and then I don't leave and be
clear that I've achieved my goal and
feel pride in esteem no totally yeah I
love all thing and I love keeping track
keeping track yes you mean like
journaling well I have this Goodreads
app and it's fun to finish a book but
it's much more fun to put it into the
Goodreads and review it and and put a
number of stars next to it I just I just
feel like it's a colletion yes yes they
wanna know my opinion on the book yeah I
really I really love the Goodreads app
and I have this RunKeeper so that that
keeps all my stats for my running and
even when I play basketball it'll keep
my heart rate and things like that I
would get addictive to that step thing
oh I don't count the steps it's just
it's just I'm a streak guy so I want to
do it five or six times a week and yeah
and keep that going so yeah I found I
find that very how it keeps me
accountable and also makes me proud that
yeah our brains need proof yes right
left to my own devices when I do
something I'll go I sucked at that that
was shitty that was alright but then I
can look at the proof and go oh no I did
50 of those squats or I did okay I can't
argue with this evidence I mean like I'm
the person that every time I go onstage
I'm like I just bombed that was horrible
right and I play a back and I'm like oh
yeah
now I know I'm much better than I
thought I would no fault I've yeah which
I think it's part of the reason we're
good comedians right you know I have
bomb years I always think I'm bombing
yeah and it makes me work harder yeah I
think it's like trying to find a balance
between that a healthy delusion that
makes you work harder and one that is
savage yeah the Bruce Springsteen you
think you have to said you you have to
think you are that you suck and that you
were a badass simultaneously I love
Bruce Springsteen yeah but there was a
point where he couldn't get out of bed
in the morning and he takes
antidepressants so yeah that was the
that was the eye-opener to me was
because you definitely have this where
you thought if I achieve and work hard
then I will feel good about myself and
then when I found out that it didn't
work for Springsteen who worked harder
than everybody and achieved more than
almost everybody but maybe Dylan maybe
and he was unhappy it's not that's when
you realize yeah but it's chemistry yeah
do not get internal needs many external
things yes yes not stuff no I would love
to talk about antidepressants okay
because you know I think we still don't
totally know the neuro chemistry of what
causes depression right I mean it's it's
it's wild how little we actually know
about the brain or anything we do know
that your dopamine receptors might not
be receiving dopamine the same way it
could also be genetic that's not a
hundred percent yet but that's something
I learned with um eating disorders and
some depression in my family and
migraines learning that something's
genetic there's a little bit of a like
okay right yeah I didn't make this up
yeah this you know I'm not victimizing
myself I'm not like trying to get
attention right and this is a biological
thing and I didn't fail right right yeah
especially with addiction where you're
like okay this train left the station
like six generations ago right my
answers my ancestors were wasted all the
time the epigenetics of what happens
like this is the first generation where
we really have any concepts right
of tools or are seeking to fix any of
them no this is just like how it was
yeah they might not have called it
depression right but my ancestors who
were in coal mines like probably they
just didn't know what the course oh I
love what you said in your special it
was what was it man up and what do you
have to be depressed about yeah yeah
yeah those were your tools growing up
yeah and suck it up yeah oh my gosh and
what do you have to be depressed about
yeah people think that it like has to do
with what oh I know I know in some way I
know so a lot of people asked on
Instagram - is what you're on an SSRI
and can you help us understand that
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor I
always get that far yeah one of them is
the cymbalta that I take is an SSRI and
I've had had good success with those
over the over the years and I I guess
it's it it keeps you from losing more
serotonin than you're losing or
something like that I don't I can't
remember the the actual chemistry behind
it but I know it's it's been very
helpful and I asked my my doctor I said
why do you think this combination has
worked and the other thing I take is
Remeron
and he said because it all these things
attack various things that may be the
cause of your depression
it's a suspenders and belt type of
approach to the but something I love so
much about you know how you talked about
this publicly is it's like you know
you're attacking it from a chemical and
behavioral person you're not just going
I'm taking antidepressant and right
that's all I have to do my work here is
done no it just got me to a level where
I was now I can go to daily work yes
exactly it seems like you really do well
with routine oh my gosh yeah and that's
why traveling is so hard yeah lose your
routine but yeah I'm really good at
routine and if it's broken
I get anxious yeah I did go on
antidepressants it for me it's I think
it it is really hard to delineate when
you're in you know you're addicted brain
codependent brain which is what I am in
recovery with eating disorder stuff
depression it's easy to kind of like
conflate all those and it took oh yeah
of course I have to go yeah I can be
depress
sometimes I can be sad but that doesn't
mean I have clinical depression right
you know having oh yeah of course yeah
sometimes it's a victory to be able to
say oh I actually don't have clinical
depression right I have these things
right and but I was and I have such bad
insomnia that for the for the longest
time I was exhausted
of course renal fatigue and I was a
walking zombie and I didn't take care of
myself and I didn't eat well and I was
in all these bad relationships you know
in first you got it like you can't just
go like I'm in this toxic relationship
I'm in a terrible job I'm making these
terrible decisions I drink every night
oh but I must have depression it's like
well you hire them all yes but I was on
I did take what was the what was the
antidepressant that was I was on
wellbutrin Olaf no Prozac no McDole no
[Music]
lexapro okay it took like some I've
taken all those by the way and and I was
on lexapro for a while because and I was
on trazadone for a minute okay watch
because the side effect of trazadone I
think is drowsiness so I was taking that
leap for a little bit cuz they were like
look literally anything's better than
ambien yeah I was waking up to like I
mean like cans open that I had like
eaten jelly out of my hand
Wow in the middle of the night this shit
that was going on Wow and so I took
trazadone I took lexapro and something I
wish they had told me was that going off
it is a whole thing yeah I tried to go
off of it cold turkey yeah that's no
joke it was rude all yeah that's why I
feel bad for people who have no choice
but to they've run out of money oh gosh
heartbreaking oh my gosh it's tragic
because I was getting those little
things dangerous I was I was literally
getting little fingers yes and my eyes
were throbbing but I was getting these
little zaps at the enemy oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah when you go off it you didn't
really have to be careful yeah they said
you have to be like a half a pill than a
whole pill that I have to put in a whole
pill for like a couple months no one
told me I was just myself oh my gosh you
know I'm working but uh but I just I
don't I think that there's so much shame
around talking
about it for most people that you don't
even think to go yeah ask questions no I
know I know you just and I think for
women there's a there's if you go in and
you're base like hey I've headache so
like here's an antidepressant really
great many people are getting it from
there yes colleges who prescribing
antidepressants look you're a woman I
just assume you're depressed you must be
have depression you know so for me one
of my big victories is going on no these
are the things I have right I don't want
to over pathologize myself miss
pathologize myself yeah and really
understanding you know kind of what it
is so for someone who is trying to
understand if this is a condition they
have or not like what are the main
things they should look at because I
think it's important to remember that
like being sad that's human sure that's
a healthy emotion sometimes it's if you
if it doesn't stop yeah that's right if
it doesn't stop if it lasts for 12 weeks
maybe even eight weeks depending on the
level you're a bad day right that's
human you know I think that yeah you
know we say in in program like
alcoholics are the only people that
think they should be having fun all the
time right and we're kind of like that
now yeah like I should always be happy
it's like well I'm I'm I'm not an
addictive personality really but I but I
do crave the excitement and and when
when you have a big project that comes
out it's so exciting and your your
adrenaline is going and you're promoting
and everybody is so excited for you and
then tomorrow
there's postpartum and luckily I had
some people who recognized or had gone
through that tell me yeah you don't want
to have to be like that all the time
part of you on the next day well I got
to work on the next thing so that I can
get this feeling again and my friends
who have been through that said it's
it's you can't win because it doesn't
happen exactly exactly
and if you need that all the time good
luck to you yeah that's a tough one and
that's that's something that's really
helped me understand like no I I don't
just like I'm entitled to always being
happy all the time sometimes gonna be
sad gonna have a bad day right
those are all healthy feelings and
sometimes what we need to do is learn to
tolerate the feelings of discomfort not
an advertisement right but the other
thing in and I said this earlier was not
enjoying things that you really used to
enjoy you don't you don't have to live
without the things that brought you
happiness and enjoy especially if there
are things that aren't that exciting but
that you looked forward to doing like I
couldn't read for two years I couldn't
concentrate and when I did read and
really enjoy it I didn't get anything
out of it and and was it like a numbness
or was that it wasn't there was a
numbness things that I used to love to
do and people that I loved to be around
I just I wanted to be alone and and so
that's another symptom and then either
too much sleep which was my case where
I'd get 14 hours and it wouldn't be
enough because I think a lot you can't
sleep
oh wow yeah and then there's anxiety
which is a lot of times coupled with
with depression where you you can't you
can't get out of your head and you have
thoughts of doom and gloom and and and
then there then there are these suicidal
ideations and I mean that I didn't
always have that but by 2015 that was
that was in my head all the time I was I
was googling I was I was so interested
in a painless way and then you always
are told growing up and never leave the
garage door closed when you start and
all I could think was when I would go to
my mother's house this is such a great
garage for filling with carbon monoxide
and then later I read that that doesn't
work anymore that they've taken
something hot out of the the car that
doesn't make it possible for you to
really in your garage I don't know if
that's that is true or maybe they just
tell you that to dissuade you but yeah
that was going through possible yeah
yeah area I couldn't I couldn't do
anything involving pain or or jumping
out like one time when I lived in LA I
stood on my I stood on my windowsill and
then I luckily realized you're going to
regret it but we're gonna injure
yourself man Oh second into the jump and
then you're still gonna be going
and so I came back in the in the
apartment but yeah it's it's I mean I've
had these feelings for so long but they
hit a and when you would think of those
things would you go don't do that was
there like it was it like a duel two
voices or was like nope that's still a
good a lot of time there was a duel
voice and then like I said in 2015-2016
it became a well we'll just we're biding
our time now but then there would be
something that would I would try that
would make me think that like the
ketamine I tried that I thought maybe
this will be the case and then the ECT
maybe this will be in that and that was
really the ECT was really helpful so my
my my wife was was very optimistic and
always looking for things and sending me
links to new ideas and new stories and
she grew mushrooms in our in our
apartment yeah and and I didn't take
them because I would I was afraid that
it would make things worse that's the
other thing you get to a point yes right
yeah it was um you know I had a but
you're not in your right mind yeah yeah
these bizarre thoughts yeah work that
aren't illogical and some people were
asking and this I thought this was a
good question about when you have this
condition and you enter in a
relationship with someone when do you
share it with them and how much do you
share I share immediately or shared
immediately yeah
like within like I want you to as soon
as as soon as the person I could tell
was interested in me I would say listen
I have had some really dark periods in
my life I feel fine enough now I'm
dating and and I feel hopeful but I can
tell you that it gets really bad and it
was it was it was something that I
started doing in my in my early 30s
because I just I thought it was it would
be cruel for somebody to find out about
this two or three months in and then
think that they've been been misled and
they were all fine with it and nobody
I've never had somebody leave me because
they couldn't tolerate it or anything
like that but I I will say that I I
begged Shaddai my wife to
leave me I was like you save yourself
kid get out get out while you still
can't bring you down the garage doors
yeah and and she's stuck by me so I'm
really I'm really happy that I've been
able to reward her patience with with
two solid years of I would ask her I
said why have you stayed and she said
well the first six months were very
strong so I I hope that you'll be able
to return there someday but no it was
crazy and then so how much do you share
this why I mean now obviously you're a
public figure and you've been sharing it
but like have you ever been in a
situation in a friendship where you
shared it and the person either didn't
understand or wasn't supportive or
didn't make you feel okay about it and
then you realize the friendship is no
longer I asked because when I started
going to meetings I did have a couple
friends that were like ah like you and
your meetings like it's just kind of you
know they say when you get healthy the
sick get angry Wow yeah that's so true
it kind of holds up a mirror and people
that have look at themselves and they
don't like it that might just yeah I
case but I noticed it normally I didn't
want me to get better yeah yeah I think
that I don't I don't know that I left
any friends but there were certain
friends where I knew yeah hey we didn't
speak I can't I can't bring this up with
this person because they give me trite
yeah responses and and so I had this one
friend who would would quote Shawshank
Redemption to get busy living or get
busy dyin type thing and I said I wish
it were I wish it were that that's the
attitude yeah he's just really soft
platitudes that really want weren't
helpful and so I slap your knee twice
yeah I think what yeah I would I would
have to keep my feelings from from them
I don't think anybody can understand it
who hasn't been through it or been near
it mm-hmm so it's it's very very hard to
explain to somebody and they don't
really understand there are people who
are actually in it who don't understand
that this is that this is just not there
their character flaw or their laziness
or things like that they
they think this is how everybody lives
I've had people message me and saying
well the idea that you're not going to
feel good about yourself until you do
something great that's just being human
and it's not there are people with much
also someone telling you they've done
anything great I wrote 45 minutes about
sugar cookies right yeah what is wrong
with these people yeah yeah they're just
adding to my insecurities I'm throwing
to break something I never do third love
uses the measurements of millions of
boobs to design bras all day for comfort
and support
remember when we were getting a third
love bra for me to try it and you asked
me my bra size yes and I said four weeks
to respond to the maintenance
I do remember it's called leverage and
then remember I said what do you think
my bra size is and I said a 38d a wild
guess what does that based on
proportions hopes yeah mostly those
things studying my body
yeah lots of gazing I finally gave you
the right size after you guessed
incorrectly about fit which was 30 well
it does vastly no one knows it's a
secret yeah it's my it so it's all it's
a it's constantly fluctuating but right
now I'm a 34c basically I have a hard
time finding bras I love this one which
is why we said yesterday this ad
sponsorship and they'll give you the
perfect size bra they're soft not I mean
the bra your boobs hopefully to fits
perfectly doesn't pull doesn't squish
from a boobs doesn't miss shape them
doesn't cut into my shoulder good clasp
yeah and that's because the quiz they
give you just answer those few simple
questions to find your size based on
what your breast size the shape and the
fit issues you have oh and then hands
down I believe this is the most
comfortable bra he'll ever own yeah I
love mine
third love I think we need to see I
don't we've lost our place my hands
animals coming bro your own do we have a
coke I need copy I like this brand I
endorsed this brand third love these are
badass bras they work I sometimes your
boobs are jiggling around not in these
that is emotion my boobs haven't moved
in weeks and they have the cups are what
sets up memory foam so it remembers what
your boob was so you don't have to start
from scratch every time you put your bra
yeah if you stay over at someone's house
make a great pillow right off third love
donates all of their gently used
returned bras to women in need
supporting charities in their local San
Francisco Bay Area and across the United
States that's freaking awesome so far
third Love has donated oh wow fifteen
million dollars in bras third love knows
is a perfect bra for everyone so right
now they're offering my listeners
Whitney's listeners 15% off your first
order go to third love comm slash
Whitney now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 50% off your first purchase
that's third love comm slash Whitney for
15% off today
get that bird ear oh I got my Rafi I
ordered those we wear them for this ad
fuck they're so cute they're black thank
you
they're so cute they had their like
little um ankle there they go up around
the ankle yes so you don't see my
ugly-ass socks I'm very into this Rafi's
stylish shoes for women and girls out of
recycled plastic water bottles that just
makes me so happy crazy comfortable
fully machine washable which was after I
stepped in horse crap I can just throw
them in the in the washing machine
quickly grown to the most loved gotta
have them brand it's so funny because I
saw everyone wearing these and now I
understand what's going on they have a
thousand nearly perfect reviews wow
they're stylish sustainable comfortable
washable me you in a shoe perfect flats
for life on the go super cute they have
all kinds of colors prints patterns what
were they on they had I mean they have
pointed toe flats round told flat yeah
have cute like loafers they have like a
little sneak lot of celebrities wear
these they're really nice they have a
tons of patterns in color yeah neutrals
and then everything from like like
animal prints prints why'd you get me
black I almost got you like the
southwestern you printed ones but then I
could just see being like
where's my animal shirt pattern I love
it so much another major major bonus is
their fuller machine washable as I said
I don't know how to use my washing
machine but when I figure it out
can't wait to wash my shoes they own and
operate their manufacturing workshop
where they prioritize sustainability
every step of the way thank God brought
these own and operate their
manufacturing wear shop where they were
tight sustainability every step of the
way plus brought these shipped directly
in their shoe box I love this there's no
unnecessary packaging every time you
order through something now you feel
like you're just like killing the
environment feel-good flats in more ways
than one you'll quickly discover it why
BuzzFeed called them there forever shoes
this is a very good Valentine's Day yeah
very good Valentine's Day gift check out
all the amazing styles available right
now on Ross's comm slash Whitney go to
Rafi's comm ro t hy s comm you guys know
how to do this slash Whitney get your
new favorite flats comfort style and
sustainability these are the shoes
you've been waiting for
Ravi's comm slash Whitney I got the
black ankle once the high tops yep I'm
curious if it gets frustrating to see
other people in a state you might have
been in or when you see like do you feel
like like when I see someone that's
struggling with addiction or
codependence or eating disorders I want
so badly to pull them aside and be like
read this book and do this and do this
but yeah it's usually like no they're
not ready to learn ready right I I mean
my my Sade said to me a lot she says
you're angry at that person because
they're not you yeah they're not they're
not applying themselves and they're not
able to be disciplined about their
treatment like like you are and they're
impatient or whatever it was that got
you through it and I said you're right
you're absolutely I know I expect people
to fix themselves overnight when it took
me 10 years right yes just do everything
I did why would you not do everything
why would you want to buy it yeah I know
I know everything right or or I want to
shake certain comedians and say why do
you why do I want you to be a better
comedian than you
want to be why but it's it's not my yeah
it's it's so it stop fucking the store
just stop fucking this door yes
that's all I ask oh I know I know God
laughing your own jokes you know I know
what you're doing stop banging yourself
with the mic oh my gosh the yes the
chappal yeah he invented it but yeah but
it's contagious too although it's just a
Pavlovian response yes I'm laughing at
Chappelle having done it a year right
yeah yeah yeah right yeah the slapping
of the thigh with the microphone yes
hold the mic lower why is your hand on
it I know I know but then I go okay what
are people saying about me I'm sure
people have their notes for me oh gosh I
I just did i if the audience the actual
audience was as abusive towards my act
as I am I would yeah that's cuz I listen
and I watch I'm like I could find so
many flaws into everything but that's
why I think you are thought of is sort
of the quintessential joke writer sorry
I put a sort of in front of that that's
nice because you are so surgical like
there is not an ounce of fat oh thank
you but all I hear is fat and the other
thing I need to I need to I've
accumulated a few people whose opinion I
trust like their taste I trust and and
because otherwise and you talked about
perfectionism where you need that person
I need that person to say it's it's good
and then I'm saying alright
take from there because otherwise I
would never release anything it's it's
and these people have said before yeah
they'll say in a very gentle way
basically yeah you don't need that yeah
or if the engine yeah yeah like the
director on this if you ever have an
opportunity to work with mike bond
figlio sounds like a nightmare he
feedback well it wasn't so much the
feedback as he listened to every every
set that I did for a year on the road
any any he knew where he wanted the
documentary stuff to go so he helped me
the story of the of the show and it
brought an narrative aspect to my to my
comedy shows that that I never had that
I'd never never bothered or really felt
I I I was capable of putting that in
there and I think that's the I think
that maybe the way that all stand-up
specials are going now or where to keep
it all in in on theme like you do that
already but I had never really done that
I just put together six or seven really
solid jokes and then and then put out a
special but I truly did that by accident
this time because I I realized like so
much of writing is just picking a
premise that you're gonna be interested
in for a year right we can all write
three jokes on Facebook and yeah coffee
you know what I mean
yeah but I picked one premise and it
didn't seem like anyone was really
talking about it exactly and I feel like
there's so many people doing comedy and
so and I was just I really was just so
afraid of doing something similar to
some rights yeah that I was like all
right no one's talking about this let me
just talk about this for for now yeah
that's the scene and then I go to the
comedy store for like three months
straight so everyone sees I'm talking
about it so no one ever thinks like yeah
cuz my biggest fear is doing something
too similar to another comedian than a
special combat look cuz most people
don't know when you shot something they
just go oh you have a similar talk to
that person and that's my living
nightmare yeah it's not like laws with
precedence in cases totally like his a
lot of people go you have a similar
jokes that person I'm like well shot ten
years ago right yeah look at the date on
the big but I get so I would just love
to say yes I stole it I stole it's
better yeah I mean I I wrote it down
word for word but then I feel like I
added some things to it so I think it's
a little bit bad at some of the fatty
there was a comic who I don't think is
really in comedy anymore and you're
about to hear why he would say I
remember one time going oh you and
so-and-so had like a really similar
which I don't do anymore I just I used
to be the person it was like let me help
everyone with everything and let me be
the messenger who saw it because I'd
want something right
yeah and then I always end up backfiring
and I was like oh so-and-so has a
similar thing I just don't want you to
just meddling in business it wasn't -
I'm alway oh my god like let me get in
some Jarama for no reason let me get
between two comedians egos that's a good
idea at midnight on Tuesday and I was
like you guys have a summer thing and he
went ah let's see who gets it on TV
first boom chillin Wow she goes down the
spine but that that I do think right now
is it's not so much about like that it's
like well a talk-show host might do it
or Twitter might do it or someone might
tweet it or but like there's so many
ways to there might be a meme about this
like I do feel a sense of rushing yeah
yeah do you feel that stress of like No
thank goodness yeah but I've been that
yeah I've been that way for a long time
and it's just it's it's a house of cards
man totally because it's one your daugh
everything's based on getting this joke
out there and and it's not yeah yeah I
want to be the fast food of comedy right
yeah and and so yeah there would there
would be certain things that I had to
drop over the years because somebody
came out with something similar on TV
and it's just sitting and you I always
knew that the more famous person was
going to get the credit for the the joke
and I mean that that would be the bottom
line so what am I gonna do it's also I
feel like people are always like how
come you tour so much like how come you
do so and it's like no the idea of a
special is you do it for nine months
yeah make sure it works in every city
right and you can you shoot it yeah
people are shooting specials after a
month and you're like no you got a right
yo work it out and find the pacing and
find that definitely no I agree with
that that's that's I mean that that was
the the sort of silver lining to getting
a special every four years rather than
every year was that I was that I was
able to work on these things for a long
time and
and in this case I also had a long time
in between when I finished riding it and
when and when it aired so I had time to
work on this this new this new tour and
then also people you know I'll be
prepared I don't think I understand how
sort of bittersweet putting a special is
out because the second it comes out you
have to have a new hour yeah yeah and
it's really annoying
no it's the most annoying yeah and and I
think there was everything contributing
to my to my depression but part of it
was putting on a special and not
immediately having inspirations yes yeah
it is complete case yeah and it has
forgotten how I got to that last one I
was like well how did I write this hour
before and and there's also this feeling
one maybe I'm one of those guys who
never wrote again after he was 45 yeah
it was yeah how was Rodney Dangerfield
when he started oh I don't I don't know
but he stopped for a long time and then
in his fifties I mean I offered it up
again yeah I always think about that I
think about Rodney Dangerfield all the
time and I I i also idolized
Larry David's career path where he was
just a writer and now he's like an icon
yeah and I remember Garry Shandling said
to me I I didn't know him very well
I was a fan obviously and I found myself
like in a room with him once at comedy
magic it was not a comedy magic it was a
David Lynch the meditation oh the
director right it was like a show like a
charity show like in the green room er
yeah yeah yeah
and we had to follow Jay Leno which was
impossible I don't think people
understand how hard Jay Leno kills yeah
he does stand-up yeah it was the
building was shaking yeah he was the
first stand-up I ever saw alive my dad
and I went to real Eckstein went to see
him at this theater in on the North
Shore of Massachusetts and my dad was in
his early 60s I was 16 and he killed
both of us we were dying dude like
hardened hipster yes
medians who uh talk shows whatever works
crying yes he was talking about um the
kickstand on a person I call like it was
that it was the tiniest premise as yeah
and his stuff from back then holds up I
mean he was machine gun killing yep so
we were all like I was stretching over
your nose no yeah doing that knee
stretch right yeah I was with Shandling
and he said something I was like
furiously writing stuff down which by
the way before a show is is just drivel
it's not I'm not really writing a joke
I'm just going through the motions no I
don't leave myself into the know
prepared he looked at me and he just
said something that was so crazy the
exact thing I needed to hear at the
exact time he goes I you know you can
never make it too late I know it was it
hit me really hard and I'm sure if
anyone else had said at any other time I
never would have heard it and it took
this weight off it's the exact thing I
needed to hear cuz I'm like I have until
38 I just had made this story up in my
head oh yeah yeah yeah based on like
women in Hollywood and high def
television and who wants to hear a woman
over 40 complaining on stage you know I
mean because there is a little bit of
like you are just a nagging woman with
the microphone because there you really
do turn into I think maybe not so much
now but my whole career I remember Kevin
Christie who used to go with me on the
road would say like about 30 minutes
into the show you turn it one man snaps
and you turn into their wife or their ex
or like their but none that that the min
heist or something really a man would
always snap like 30 minutes into one of
my shows like I remember one time
that's no interesting I was in La Jolla
that doesn't relie happen anymore Benton
it's more like women yelling ya know
that doesn't happen all men release seem
to enjoy you and women throw things at
you it's amazing gift compliment mace
amaze that's through me pink maze woods
I remember I was in La Jolla California
have you been down that La Jolla Comedy
Store no it's so great no it's
it's legendary it so here's the not the
first comedy story I don't know what do
I know but it's like a box okay it's
just so many comedy venues now are like
old banks and just the the the sound
does not reverberate or Dan Soder said
that one of the clubs was a closed laser
tag dude few low ceilings exactly low
space and why never understand that
which is people why does everyone love
the cellar so much it's that's alright
and the comedy connection was like that
it Hudson Wright house in Fanueil Hall
yeah it was perfect I remember walking
in there I'm like whoa this is a
nightmare you have to look at both sides
you got a swivel and then I understood
this is like yeah old Gotham okay yeah
that was I mean
identical to that that the dimensions
sort of of the or the set up of the
cellar and the comedy connection of
Fanueil Hall because I think a lot of
people like why does everyone love this
club so much it like the conditions you
know you know and this is a perfect box
in very low ceilings and it's just the
greatest it's just like when it hits
nothing feels better than that place
yeah but anyway I was doing a joke at
the time about like I was so dumb it was
like about some like how guys always
have like a bowl of coins yeah look true
[Laughter]
that's how comedians laugh they just go
true that's a great ovation like a jar
like there's always a couple receipts in
it like a proclaim yeah and a ring it's
it's best the best example is is
Reservoir Dogs when when when mr. orange
is going out on the on the caper he goes
into that that but that dish and he
finds his lucky ring ah that's a
brilliant observation like a class ring
or football ring or a piece of hard
candy
take a couple random miscellaneous like
pina colada candies yeah it kinda
filling yeah a fortune from a fortune
couple international coins even though
you've never traveled abroad yeah couple
pieces of track because I think it's
guys just empty their pockets yes
was whatever's in their pockets goes in
the jar yes and I think you one day
aspired at taking it to a coin star yeah
and that never happened no it never
happens so I was doing some joke about
that I don't know what it was and I was
like so every guy has a jar and there
was this guy in the front row who asked
me for tickets he like had it was the
time I had emailed and we'd get people
free tickets and whatever Wow that's
back when I like thought that was a good
idea because when people don't pay for
tickets they're always act like it's a
free show don't value it there's no
value unless there's value yeah you're
worth nothing right sure you that way
yeah so he's in the front row and he was
laughing the whole time I mean almost to
the point of it being like disruptive
like clapping dirt you know I'm like
this guy's the best like I have the best
life like what a great lease is what
makes it all worth it look how much fun
this guy's having yeah this is why we do
this joy on this man's face and then I'd
say 30 minutes and I'm like so every guy
has a jar full of coins right and he
just goes cold and he goes that's so we
can pay for your shit I just walked into
a landmine I just walked into a hornet's
nest that I would like to carefully
extricate myself from Wow snapped so he
had to get kicked out yeah have to
yelling at me yeah like an epic went
outside and then the way La Hoya's
designed there's a big window and he
stood outside and just stared at me the
rest of the set through the window oh my
god
that's brutal I used to I feel like it's
a nightmare walk into people's stuff oh
yeah yeah yeah people understand how
like you know it can be very dangerous
yeah I agree and yeah in this strange
intimacy yes yeah and this this level of
trust right well you're all gonna while
you're drinking maybe on empty stomachs
yeah letting steam off we're all just
gonna agree that you're gonna be sane
yeah did you see the CAPA Rouleau thing
No can you pull up John Capel reuleaux
Hermosa I like that guy this is he's the
best although I haven't seen him
probably in 12 years I haven't seen him
in a while yeah
someone threw a glass at him at hermosa
nominee magic No did you see the Andy
Dick the guy that punched Andy Dick in
the back of the head
no oh dude where was that oh you got to
get my algorithm you're in the wrong
algorithm
dude this is wild okay so a lady yelled
fuck you oh this lady is leaving she's
leaving she's grabbed her Aldo purse and
she's out of there she's grabbing that
coat that she got at art and be out I'm
gone wait I'm cringing I can't handle
this this is making me so uncomfortable
oh no I'm already upset but he doesn't
even seem to be shaking why does that
happen every night yeah question yeah
that is that is true we haven't watched
the Eddie Dick one right this Andy Dick
one is so upset this happened after a
show in New Orleans someone came up
behind Andy Dick and just knocked him
out for 15 and why didn't why didn't
trump come up in that in that she was a
trump supporter he he made a pejorative
joke about Trump okay and she got upset
oh no reason to throw a human being nor
disrupt the show nor disrupt the show
you leave if you need yeah of course you
need to leave I get that I'm not for
everyone that is my big thing I'm
finally department like you know I'm not
for everyone yeah I'm god I don't have
time to change anything more about
myself right this is it yeah this is
might be the best I can do this is my
best version this is so upsetting this
is a guy who was on stage with him I'm
sorry who was after he was not safe huh
Wow he was look at him he was out for 15
minutes and lit grabs his beer walks
away oh that's really upsetting sorry
bumming you out
no but punch that Andy Dick sure walks
away no one knows what to do that's the
most depressing part route no one's
actually doing anything about it yeah
I truly love this I'm obsessed with this
I had peanut butter whiskey by myself
the other day I felt great about you I
was watching Netflix
I saw the peanut butter whiskey because
they sent it for the ad and I was like
you know what I'm gonna indulge myself
and it was a delicious it is really good
it's a perfect like sweet bug it's so
sweet it's just like peanut butter
peanut butter cup oh so delicious anyway
that's my I put some in coffee like you
said no at night I was like I'm gonna
have a night coffee oh my gosh you could
put in hot chocolate to that I think
that's a really good peanut butter hot
chocolate I mean it's what you actually
said and I just maybe yeah where are
everything starting to blur together at
this point warm welcoming aroma
deliciously smooth palate screwball
peanut butter whisky isn't your average
flavored liqueur I've never had another
one but this is the only one I would
drink made by a local husband-and-wife
duo whoa with American whiskey and
peanut butter flavor the end result is
savory it's creamy touch of sweetness
and without the lingering heavy finish
you might expect this is all true
there's a reason why it won all the
awards the double medal gold medal the
Olympics of alcohol I love it screwball
original and most awarded peanut butter
whiskey is now available nearly
everywhere it's 70 proof that explains a
lot about how the resident I went for me
screwball peanut butter whiskey is the
perfect shot for the perfect addition to
your favorite cocktail pick it up at
your local store ask for it at your
favorite bar a restaurant oh my god
that's such a good idea
I need a hashtag get screwed yes hashtag
gets screwed screwball whisky.com for
more information please drink
responsibly advertisement by screwball
spirits LLC san marcos CA whiskey with
natural flavours of caramel color 35
percent alcohol by volume
I hope this couple stays together look
around I didn't get these headphones no
nope I got them look did your 15 of them
I got these headphones and they are
awesome they're awesome because they go
right into your ears which I think I
unlike other heads yes because you know
I have this piercing on this ear right
here so I need headphones to go right
into my little
hole okay and these headphones did it so
I'm very into them and that's why we are
going to try to sell them to everyone
else now before you go dropping hundreds
of dollars on a pair of headphones you
need to check out wireless earbuds from
rake on how cool is that sound wait con
it sounds like a convention you want to
go to please correct you already know
rake on earbuds start at about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds headphones are ridiculously
expensive Oh God yeah rate cons latest
model e 25 they're their best one yet
with six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and more
compact design and gives you a nice
noise isolating fit this is true I can I
can attest that that's correct statement
rate cons why are those earbuds are so
comfortable they're perfect on-the-go
listening especially if you have weird
piercings in your ear like I do they go
right in they're cute they don't and
they also don't tangle up right away oh
I love that yeah well you've heard me
talk about the company being co-founded
by Ray J and celebrities like cardi B oh
yeah she's and we use because she does
she tells no lies she said oh come pick
up a pair see what all the hype is about
now's the time to get the latest and
greatest from recon 15% off your order
at buy rake on Comm slash Whitney that's
buy break on.com slash Whitney for 15%
off rake on wireless earbuds that are
already affordable I don't know how they
do it but they did it by rake on dot-com
slash quit
oh it's brutal
it's brutal oh you gonna keep your head
on a swivel mouth after the show oh
that's really upsetting isn't that scary
I think yeah I mean I remember you know
Jim Jefferies might be like hey I mean
that was the first real I think
comic assault that we all kind of knew
about right person that knocked him out
on stage you know you just it's you're
right there your hairy feet away from a
mob of people yeah who could turn on you
at any moment yeah that's that's true I
always forget that yeah you know yeah
and there is something in everyone that
a certain phrase or a little whiskey
yeah yeah have you ever seen something
like that like a dangerous situation
well I'm trying to think I mean recently
at the Comedy Cellar I got offstage and
the guy yelled you suck and I mean I had
made such the the the lightest Donald
Trump insult it was just I I said
something about Abraham Lincoln being
our best president and then I said up
till now up till now yeah and the guy
was very upset that I did that I had
been so insulting like it's not even it
it's real I didn't call him Hitler
yeah that's not even a real flam yeah I
said you suck and I said what this is
too political too political so that that
was recent and then and then years ago a
guy threw a drink in my face yeah yeah
while you were on scene no no I got when
I got offstage that the comedy improv I
think and and then I was like oh if
somebody throws a drink in your face I
think you have to punch them did you
punch them um
no luckily gene pompa did what yeah does
anyone have you ever punched someone
before uh yeah and it's not as effective
as it looks on television I feel like
yeah when I was eight when I was 18 I
got into a fistfight in it and they're
like I was like I keep hitting this guy
and he's still he's still going but it's
where do you even how do you know even
where to get like are men just born with
the ability to know how to punch someone
no I think you have to be taught because
I didn't know what what where do I just
look for got a guy punched me in the
face I was like oh boy I think I have to
here we go it hurt doing this did it
hurt when he punched me no because I
wasn't expecting it so I think
adrenaline yeah and then when I woke up
the next day I was like oh this is
really painful and I had cuts and
abrasions and then yeah but it seemed
like this guy was it was just that there
was nothing I could do to really faze
him it was yeah it's just Boston its
thought yeah it's the hardest part about
being a guy is that you you well you
could also get in a fight as a woman but
it's much more likely as a guy
especially in Boston that you you may
have to defend yourself with your fists
at some point because it's it's not just
punch in the face yeah it certainly is
but then but then you would have to go
to the police and explain yes it's also
it's also demeaning in your telling me
yeah I should keep this to yourself was
Boston especially rough to grow up in
yeah yeah yeah because the the the
masculinity thing and the the homophobia
so that the things that were really not
sexual at all could be construed as
being being gay just an interest in
hygiene crap showering crafts I remember
being averse to I I really I I was I was
a guy who liked to draw and and make
things and and work with clay and then
all the sudden it was like yeah Keith
you might want to keep that to yourself
kid yeah so that was something you felt
you were discouraged from doing anything
artistic yeah or even my brother
my oldest brother had this thing where
if I was where if I was being sensitive
or like we would roughhouse or something
like that and I would I would tell my
mother he was 13 years older than me by
the way I would tell my mother and he
would be like go read a book you know
what I won't even I won't even play with
you discover you to both
oh yeah but he yeah he's feeling that's
changing yes yes completely I think I
think that we might be going too far the
other direction maybe but I'd rather
that then then what I grew up with where
you were you had to just keep a stiff
upper lip over really serious things
like I just remember I was thinking
about this the other day because I'm I
have a book deal so I'm writing this
this book and I'm thinking about how I
handled my first breakup and I just
would not tell anybody that I felt
anything about it
okay yeah because I was so embarrassed
that I had feeling that I had feelings
and that I was sad and and I didn't want
and then my family was it was was just
like it's enough already it's yeah it's
been a month move on and yeah it was
like and then so when I had these
feelings even the following year it was
like keep that to yourself you're gonna
bomb everybody out and people are gonna
are gonna go tired and impatient with
you so yeah I'm I'm glad it's it's swung
this way but I mean do you think it was
it's interesting cuz a lot of my
girlfriends and I talked about this when
people talk about like toxic masculinity
were you know I I will say and whether
the the whether it's a good or bad thing
to say I don't know I'm sure I'll get
shit for it but you know I have dated a
lot of very ostensibly tough men right
rowdy men sportsmen you know guys that
played you know right sports and all
that guy but in relationships we see the
soft side of men right they we see it
we're kind of like what masculinity
crisis right hopefully when he's sick
he's like cries yeah you know like we
sort of a lot you know
of men do feel safer on women I think
but around each other not much but I
think a lot of my girlfriend's like what
masculinity crisis yeah I don't know I
think that one one one thing with the
with the special that I found very
interesting is guys who I never expected
to come up to me after the shows or just
just old-time friends a friend who was
it who is like a mentor to us when we
were in
Highschool he came up to me and said I I
had to have my wife watch it with me so
she would understand why I have these
moves I think so that was really I made
really really special then this was a
guy who was a superior athlete and I
think went to either West Point or
something like laughs that or did played
sports in college and and was a leader
and and a mentor to a lot of us and it
turns out that he had the same thing so
that's that's something that a lot of
guys have-have have approached me about
and I remember one time being in
Rochester New York and a guy with a
do-rag on who clearly had access to a
motorcycle and which was seem like the
toughest guy and he came up to me
afterwards and told me about his
struggles and I and I thought oh it'll
work everywhere what just by the way
also I do think we need to capsize our
paradigm about it because admitting you
have something like this that is
actually the bravest most badass thing
you can do you know because it is the
scariest thing like it's so interesting
that anyone would ever see that as weak
because it's actually the tribe you are
the toughest person in the room if you
say like I have bipolar disorder like
that's the biggest badass in the room
the bravest thing it is getting through
that to get through that and tell about
it that that takes a lot of like going
that's easy
yeah you played football you said in
college and didn't appreciate you
football's gonna stay around no I hope
not do you think yeah I feel 30 years
and be like sit in a crime every time I
watch a game I think yeah we used to
just like make people get concussions
for the thrill of right and and I hear
these guys complaining about the the
celebrations or or the knee taking and
and and I think I give these guys a lot
of leeway as far as their celebrations
go because they're risking our lot their
lives for our entertain a lot of them
dance around yes I remember watching
someone I was watching the some game
over the holiday I can't tell you which
one and all their hair was really long
oh yeah I love that and I was like
trying to write a joke about it I was
like huh and then I was like like why is
there so long I'm like they're dying
exactly i at anymore yes they yes and
the in the contracts I have no problem
yeah they've got about eight years to
earn their money yes it is really um it
is really it is so barbaric why is it so
fun to watch well I don't know but it is
it is it is
I think modern-day Coliseum yeah it's
Rome that's no that's the great analogy
yeah isn't that basically what really is
yes I love watching gladiators totally
and I think if they didn't have helmets
on not only were they not I think it'd
be harder because you don't see their
face right you're just like these are
yeah not real humans I know yeah
no it's so true that that helps to not
to not feel as much empathy I know a
football player who said I was like oh
my god have you had more than three
concussions he's like we oh yeah we only
count them when we go out right we get
them all the time but you don't want to
lose yes screen time what do you call it
stage playing time playing time stage
time red light on the field yeah but um
they don't want to say cuz they don't
want to go off the field so they get
concussions it's only three that are
recorded right that create the CTE s are
called so they say if you get three
concussions that's when you get CTE yeah
go get them all the time but they they
also talk about these micro concussions
and yeah it's terribly and it's also
football's gotten better cuz they've
done these drone shots now oh yeah oh my
god the camera cuz I've never been more
comparable of it yes they've never been
faster they've never been more athletic
and yeah it's still happening - oh yeah
rugby is still happening and people
still box and and III soccer is actually
the worst for concussion yeah yeah but
then I always think in UFC that that
they beat each other up
then they hug and I always say how about
we try they just hug it first and see if
they still want to find it yeah after
that like and then they say it's not
your fault like it's good
hunting it's not your fault and then
they cry in each others arms I mean I
think it's a little is well I guess they
don't have the padding on their hands
but is UFC seems like it's more you can
say no thank you
yes yes yes
I give I like I'm good yeah yeah yeah
like I remember there was a Ronda Rousey
like people would just as soon as it
would come close to the armbar they yeah
yeah yeah oh my gosh that do you think
what do you think is the only thing
that's scarier than doing stand-up I
think it might be athletics yeah I mean
I wasn't being a goalie right in soccer
yeah that to me seems like an yeah or in
hockey - oh there's solo space how'd ya
and that thing is so small and you have
to see through a mask it's it's just
everything is working against you with
all these guys and then there's this
because people like stand-ups the
scariest thing in the world and I'm like
no I've done things that I was more
nervous about doing and football was one
and also getting into the batter's box
against a really fast picture when I was
in a little league this kid I'm like I
can't see the ball how am I going to hit
it and what if it hits me so much you
get to control everything yes you can
prepare we're going at my pace yeah I
don't have to rely on someone else to
tell me when if it's not going well
I can totally address that right like
the conditions we get to set early yes
it's a control freak dream yes and and
also you can quit any time you want you
can do your last show at any point
there's no everything you want yeah yeah
and inevitably you're like I want to go
back to oh great last thing I'm gonna
ask you so I know you have to go to your
nap and get you to your routine both of
our perfectionism sorry
I want you here longer but you have to
take care of yourself thank you just can
we do like a quick like the things that
you know if you've seen the special
you'll know a lot of it like the things
that have been the most helpful for you
just like a little speed round well one
one thing was I found this quote by
Samuel Beckett who haven't other than I
think he wrote Waiting for Godot
I read and I know then it went right
through me I couldn't tell you really
what happens it just didn't it didn't
adhere to it any of my brain cells
didn't stay so I don't I don't know what
happened in it I just remember thinking
this is way too smart for me but he had
this quote where he said ever tried ever
failed no matter
try again fail again fail better and the
fail better sentence is the one that
relieved me of all the the I better be
perfect and if the joke doesn't work I'm
going to be devastated I won't be able
to there were days where the show went
fine except for a new joke didn't work
and I'd wake up the next day and think
I'm doomed I'm never going to write
another new joke and then just the
acceptance of the amount of failing that
I'd have to do and that was that was
such a relief you do is everyone should
follow Gary on Twitter because you do
these sort of advice on oh yeah well I
ended that on December 31st I did it 103
366 tips that is I've stopped so you can
go back yeah you can go back through it
and I think when I have writer's block I
was like go through it and oh yeah
that's right it doesn't matter what it
is or go through your old notebooks yes
that was really helpful yes yes and me
and you think oh I'm a good enough
comedian to make it work now yeah I have
the right audience to make it work now
because look how hard I've tried for so
long yes I'm not a complete piece of
shit yes and has all these trash notes I
made something good out of so let me
make more trash notes totally most of it
that's a great point I think it's so
important that with writers of anything
music scripts books blogs tweets
whatever you want to do is like first
drafts are supposed to suck yes that's
the why it's called a first draft just
get something down yes so what I do even
with some days when I write I only do
premises
this is premise day great no punch line
set I'll even write in bold joke yeah
like the jokes gonna come at some point
right just premise premise promise
promise promise promise promise yeah and
just just seeing a bunch of shit on a
piece of paper code makes me feel like
I'm not talking trash yes and and I also
found that if I said just right for 15
minutes yeah I would look up two hours
later and I'm still writing it was the
starting that was so that was so hard
we're just exercise for five minutes
perfection perfectionism leads to
procrastination which leads to paralysis
yes so you're just getting start yeah
which leads to depression I think which
and also I do things I have a little
hourglass that I use it's a turn even an
hourglass yeah and just looking at it
and kind of just like yeah I have to
sort of yeah you know and I think TM has
been helpful and and running and playing
basketball and those things have been
really helpful and then therapy yeah and
then I I go to this this mood disorder
support group in New York that's cool
it's every Wednesday I think that's so
important like you know I think therapy
is obviously if you can afford it you
know great but for me and the kind of
stiii really need to be in a group of
strangers yeah that I that humble me and
make me go cuz I'm only going to therapy
it's like I start getting this idea that
I'm special and right and I get to
control it and I can also apply to a
therapist I know you know when I go to a
group of people it really it you know
this white 12-step programs you know
work so well for me is you're just like
everyone else everyone's gone through
something right and I'm gonna admit
something disgusting about myself in
front of a group of people and they're
all gonna go totally right not a big
deal yeah only as sick as your secrets
it's a 12-step programs work cuz you
admit something the most disgusting vile
embarrassing nasty thing about yourself
and everyone just goes yeah I've done
that yeah but do you think also I found
this to be the case for from my friend
and for me because I was very lonely
when I would go with her to the to the
12-step programs and it was just I now
have a dozen people sometimes more
around me and I feel better immediately
immediately and they've got nothing from
you yeah they don't care what you do and
they haven't cast you in a role yes they
don't know anything about you so they're
not gonna call whatever happen with that
yes we're making yes I remember Kurt
Vonnegut saying that a a is the is the
greatest religion the most effective
religion because it cures the loneliness
oh so good yeah and you're also being of
service to other people yes sir
yeah sounds so nerdy but it's yeah I'm
like warning but it's it actually makes
you feel better that's how you build a
self-esteem yes you say this on the show
you do with steam Abul action so just
being there for someone else and taking
the focus off yourself for five fucking
minutes yeah this should be such an
artistic disease you know and just and
just listening to someone else and also
hearing you know something horrific
we're like okay the fact that that
person didn't respond to my email yeah
is not the biggest thing that's ever had
a think twain said you want to cheer
yourself up cheer somebody else up oh so
good yeah
like because I think that we're in this
thing we're like my thing in my hate my
son then I'll help people like that I'm
a piece of shit in the center of the
universe around how big of a piece in
our vagina yes you know my words just
taking the focus off yourself and this
is one little thing the last thing I'll
say is um I read that Sheryl Sandberg
book on grief okay I don't remember it
was called the lean in book was not I
have thoughts on that I have a lot of
notes that book was basically like just
get five nannies it was like a book for
the 1% of women than having millions of
dollars Wow
but she her husband died like really
suddenly out of nowhere and this grief
counselor said to her imagine all the
ways it could have been worse which is
like the most fucked-up thing like when
I first read it I was like that's just
like masochistic and Ryan the district
of this person but it was her husband
died like on a treadmill just I think an
aneurysm or something and then part of
what he told her to do was imagine how
it could have been worse and she's like
oh well he could have been driving and
the kids had been right yeah and she was
like oh my god I feel better that's
really interesting so reminds me that
Tony Robbins thing or something bad
happens and you're supposed to say how
is this great oh yeah yeah that's a very
good one I read um I like that fill
stats book the tools to it's kind of
he's a therapist who his focuses on
addiction in 12-step and he has a
something called the deathbed exercise
where you imagine yourself on your
deathbed thinking about
life Wow and I do that with food where
I'm like if I'm like ever obsessing
about like calories or something I think
of myself on my deathbed going like how
did you waste so much of your life
thinking about that stupid denying its
public jealous of someone oh yeah I was
I thinking about that person you know
you put yourself on your deathbed yeah
that's a great perspective just to stop
worrying about shit that doesn't matter
I love it that won't matter later yeah
oh no doubt that one um your tour is
happening yes I get to come see you
tonight yeah I can't wait I can be
awesome yeah and toggle ass is gonna be
there cool yeah it's like you're doing a
bunch of cities or yeah I think almost
30 Gary Gulman doc yeah yeah edu tom has
all my date book not out yet in process
right Twitter a thousand page a thousand
words at a time I'm at that time going
to yeah right at least a thousand page a
thousand words a day a thousand words a
day
really yeah that's going to measure it
on your yeah there's a word count on the
UH non words so I love that I just asked
how a computer works is there a way to
find out how many work believe it or not
yeah and then Instagram and the Great
Depression
on HBO HBO streaming now brilliant don't
thank you don't be silly offerings it's
game changer thank you I like to answer
this powerful yeah it's your fun oh so
much fun oh good with me yeah
[Music]